- [Angelo] You think they
ready to sing, Dirty Walt?
- [Walter] Yeah, let's see.
- [Angelo] You think
they ready to sing, Jay?
- [Walter] Let's get
that sunshine shit goin'!
- [Angelo] Come on, help me out now!
- [Walter] Come on, sing it!
♫ Everyday sunshine
- Back then, we’d get a lot of
guys playing that white boy music,
and we really don't listen to that,
you know, and it's going too fast.
- To finally get to a
place where there is now
a sea of all the rainbows of people,
but a lot of black kids there.
We're at the point of progress.
- [Angelo] I hear from
a lot of people of color
say you guys made it okay
for me to feel like it was
alright to be black and rock.
I hear that a lot.
- [Narrator] Brooklyn's
Afropunk Music Festival
was born in 2005 for
alternative black culture.
But before there was a
space for celebration,
a strong handful of bands
were paving the way,
like the band Fishbone.
- [Angelo] My name is Angelo Moore,
frontman of Fishbone.
- [John] I'm John Norwood Fisher,
bassist for Fishbone.
Fishbone was formed in the late 70's,
and it was Los Angeles, 1978.
- [Angelo] Weren't too many
bands that looked like us,
because all black bands
playing punk rock and ska,
probably count it on one hand.
♫ Sunshine
- The crazy part about it was,
while we were starting to play a lot
of rock and roll, we really weren't
embraced too much by the black public.
We were embraced a lot
by the white public,
so we’d get a lot of white
kids coming to the show.
Black people ain't supposed to play rock.
That's not the stereotype.
Black people are supposed to
play R&B and funk and soul.
If you got dreadlocks, you
supposed to be playing reggae.
- If you put on a suit
and tie, you play jazz.
- You can play jazz, right?
(laughter)
Afropunk is a celebration
of rock and roll,
black music for everyone.
- [John] It's incredible and
it draws in youth of color
to say this is for you in
a larger way than we did.
- [Angelo] You can be the
beautiful black you, and rock.